є скаже що буде підтримувати Україну
стільки скільки буде потрібно але шлях
до вступу в Європейський союз ще довгий
оскільки повномасштабна війна триває вже
другий рік що сталося з відчуттям
терміновості щодо членства яке за
словами Києва було таким життєво
важливим і якщо до коштів обіцяних але
не наданих моя гостя цього тижня
Катерина барлі заступниця голови
Європарламенту чи дійсно ЄС хоче
Перемоги України
ми в Україні зброя яку ще навіть не
взяли на озброєння власної армії тому що
вона найсучасніша з найсучасніших і я
думаю що цей свідчить про нашу
відданість
зараз ЄС наполягає на тому що Україна
окрім війни за виживання також має
реформувати свою судову систему та
подолати корупцію але враховуючи що
європейські парламент потонув у так
званому лобійському скандалі катаргейт
Хіба це не чистий лицемірство як довго
чиновники ЄС самі закривали очі на
правила етику та чесність
Катерину барлі Ласкаво просимо у
конфлікт-зон Дуже дякую Тіми
незважаючи на визнання того що Україна
бореться за західні цінності і гине за
них є зруйнує сподівання Києва на
швидкий вступ Ви самі нещодавно сказали
що Україні ще потрібно пройти довгий
шлях до вступу в ЄС Мені цікаво чи
можете ви уявити як це повинно
заохочувати людей які навіть не знають
чи будуть вони живі завтра і чи
стоятимуть їхні будівлі
насправді ЄС діє в дуже-дуже швидко
підтримуючи Україну набагато швидше ніж
ми звикли насправді протягом трьох днів
ми підтримали Україну фінансову зброю чи
ми раніше не робили і санкціями і навіть
коли Справа доходить до вступу ми
зробили Україну Україною кандидатом
знебаченою раніше швидкістю але це
велика країна поза Європейським Союзом
це те що нам взагалі доведеться жити
протягом тривалого часу тому робити це
потрібно обережно
але те що Україна хотіла за словами
Ольги стефанішиної віце-прем'єрки з
питань євроінтеграції це зберегти
відчуття терміновості щодо членства
України а не зволікати вони просять
забагато
ми це зробили як я вже сказала Ми
зробили Молдову та Україну українами
кандидатами Хоча вони не відповідають
критеріям і визнаються У нас є три типи
критеріїв політичні такі як демократія
верховенство права тощо економічні Ви
повинні бути в змозі не відставати
економічно і має бути певний ступінь
узгодженості в законах нічого з цього
немає ні в Україні ні в Молдові і
все-таки ми зробили їх країнами
кандидатами і вони хоч і вимагають цього
публічно але якщо ви з ними поговорите
Вони це дуже цінують тому що це йде
паралельно з фінансової допомоги
наприклад що ж до фінансової допомоги
повернемося за хвилину але Міністр
закордонних справ України Дмитро Кулеба
очікував на відчутні практичні
результати від своїх останніх зустрічей
у Брюсселі але ви не змогли йому нічого
дати тож Дозвольте мені поставити
запитання від його імені чи збирається
ЄС почати переговори про вступ цього
року Україна не бачить жодних причин
цього не робити
як я вже сказала якщо ви поспілкуєтеся з
українськими офіційними особами то вони
добре знають що до них ставилися так як
до жодної іншої країни раніше дуже-дуже
прихильно і як я вже сказала Підтримка
яку ЄС надає Україні зараз у війні є
видатною звичайно офіційні особи
продовжують цей тиск але під час вступу
до Європейського Союзу є дві сторони
країна яка вступає і Європейський союз
який повинен мати можливість прийняти їх
на борт а в Україні 45 мільйонів жителів
думаю це була б третя за величиною
Україна в Європейському Союзі Тому це не
лише політичне рішення цей процес
вимагає ретельної підготовки і я
абсолютно впевнена що офіційні особи це
прекрасно розуміють
ви особисто пропустили що прискорення
проходження процедури для України було б
несправедливим щодо інших країн
кандидатів яким довелося довго чекати
Вибачте але чи є серед них ті чи є міста
і села бомбардує над держава їхніх жінок
ґвалтували їхніх дітей депортували їхніх
чоловіків катували і розстрілювали в
потилицю через захист європейських
цінностей Бо якщо ні то чи не варто їм
поступитися місцем у черзі країні яка
усе це терпить заради всього континенту
включно з вами
вони це роблять багато з цих країн
чекали понад 10 років навіть на те щоб
стати країною кандидатом Боснія ігор
цього вина наприклад Щойно отримала цей
статус через 10 років Тож вони бачать цю
різницю так само добре як і ми і ми
діємо Таким чином але якщо ви подивитеся
наприклад на північну Македонію Ця
країна навіть змінила назву тому що є
Греція та Болгарія для яких є проблемою
якщо б Македонія називалася Македонією і
вони це зробили хоч це звичайно не Така
сама ситуація як в Україні
добре Давайте поговоримо про те яку
підтримку ви їм надаєте ще у травні
президент єврокомісії оголосив про пакет
фінансової допомоги в розмірі 9
мільярдів євро майже півроку потому цей
пакет досі залишається предметом
суперечок між країнами-членами чому
у нас є система де фактично України і
члени самі по собі тому що Європейський
Союз не має власної компетенції щодо
зовнішньої політики тож фактично Україна
і члени роблять свій внесок у допомогу
Україні і я можу сказати про свою країну
що ми надаємо мільярди для України і
багато інших держав-членів також зробили
це тож те що робить Європейський союз
загалом це доповнення хоч люди іноді
вірять що Європейський союз це
інституція яка володіє купою грошей це
не так річний бюджет Європейського Союзу
це приблизно 180 мільярдів здається що
це багато але порівняно з німецьким
бюджетом наприклад це дуже мала сума
тому є країни-члени які допомагають
Україні Німеччина Франція Польща країна
Балтії є дуже чудово Це роблять особливо
ті країни які близькі до України
Ukraine
але затримки Катерину барлі затримки
завдали значних страждань українцям Олег
устенко радник президента України з
економічних питань сказав що наш міністр
фінансів перебуває під надзвичайно
сильним тиском коли він надсилає ці чеки
військовим у пенсійні фонди ці гроші
повинні бути у нього в руках тому
затримка на тиждень чи скільки просто
неприйнятна він має рацію чи не так
Наскільки я знаю Україна має надзвичайно
високі видатки з усіх боків військові та
цивільні наприклад треба платити своїм
державним службовцям тому Наскільки я
знаю допомога До речі не тільки від
Європейського Союзу але й допомога
міжнародної спільноти завжди вчасно
доходила до України
Справа в тому що більше половини з 30
мільярдів євро обіцяних як ЄС та і
європейським інвестиційним банком тобто
Найбільша частка бюджетної підтримки
заходу досі не надійшли до Києва Це 17 з
половиною мільярдів євро із 30-ти чи не
ризикуєте ви надто багато обіцяти Та не
до виконати
зараз як я вже сказала основні внески
роблять країни-члени і я можу лише
повинна сказати що я ніколи не мала
подібних дискусій тому що зазвичай те що
відбувається зараз сприймається якщо з
цілком надзвичайне і сума Які
європейські держави і звичайно також в
США та інші жертвують надають допомогу
Україні є абсолютно надзвичайними це
такі Суми які ці країни ви знаєте вони
там не лежали в очікуванні коли їх
надішлють в Україну тож для всіх цих
країн Це чимало зусиль і вони йдуть на
це і я думаю що це справді заслуговує
певної поваги
[музика]
Міністерка фінансів США у жовтні не
приховувала свого Роздратування з
приводу затримок у надходженні грошей в
Україну вона сказала що донори повинні
продовжувати збільшувати масштаб
допомоги а передбачуваність і грантова
частина виплат мають покращитися те саме
сказав Якоб кірка гард з німецького
фонду Маршала він висловився ще більш
прямо за його словами іншим членом
Великої сімки не в останню чергу
звичайно США цілком очевидно що Європа
підстраховується або як завжди зволікає
не зовсім та картина яку ви собі малюєте
сьогодні з брюсселя
так і це не те враження яке в мене
склалося Я маю на увазі що як я вже
сказала усі ці країни повинні
мобілізувати гроші величезні Суми грошей
і вони цим займаються
я не хочу говорити про свою країну
Давайте поговоримо про такі країни Як
Польща та країни Балтії і подивимося яку
вони надають військову допомогу як я вже
сказала те чого ми ніколи раніше не
робили доставляючи всілякі матеріальні
засоби військову техніку доставляючи
гроші та іншу всеохоплюючу допомогу
звичайно ми повинні продовжувати це
робити І ми дуже віддані цьому Ми будемо
це робити
наприклад канцлер Шульц завжди казав що
ми повинні підтримувати Україну доти
доки це буде потрібно і ми будемо це
робити
доти доки це потрібно для чого щоб
виграти чи вижити яка межа цього
доки Україна готова воювати Я думаю що
Україні і тільки Україні вирішувати як і
коли ця війна коли їм почати діє щодо
припинення цієї війни Коли їм розпочати
переговори про її завершення не вони це
починали Отже вони єдині хто може
сказати ось момент коли ми готові до
переговорів переговорів про що завгодно
тільки вони це можуть визначити
але Правда в тому що Захід не дав
Україні достатньо для перемоги чи не так
Ігор Жовква головний зовнішньополітичний
радник президента Зеленського це дуже
чітко сформулював Він сказав що якби ми
отримували достатню підтримку ми б уже
виграли війну і сьогодні в святкували
перемогу з вами у чомусь він правий чи
не так виникає запитання чи дійсно є
схоче щоб Україна виграла цю війну
я не військовий експерт і я не знаю чи
ви ним є Я цілком розумію що позиція
президента Зеленського його радників і
уряду полягає в тому щоб закликати
давати все більше і більше і це Звичайно
цілком зрозуміло
давайте подивимося Що єс хоче від
України щодо реформ головне місце в
списку змінить щодо судового нагляду та
боротьба з корупцією Цікаво скільки
реформ на вашу думку могла провести
Німеччина якби у неї вторглася Росія
питання не в тому що потрібно робити
зараз але я маю сказати що Президент
Зеленський дійсно вже важливий заходів
проти корупції під час війни тому що він
бачить що навіть під час війни в Україні
є люди які на цьому заробляють які
продають товари за високу ціну купуючи
українські товари набагато дешевше тобто
в країні є корупція і президент
Зеленський зовсім недавно я думаю кілька
тижнів тому вже важливих заходів щодо
цього тому що зараз це також в інтересах
країни але звісно не ми повинні говорити
Їм Зараз у цій ситуації і під час війни
що ви повинні зробити те і те і судову
систему тощо все це буде обговорюватися
після війни у процесі відновлення і
звичайно під час процесу вступу в ЄС
Але іронічного чи не так що боротьба з
корупцією є однією з ключових вимог ЄС
до України саме в той час коли
європарламент потопає у власному
корупційному скандалі відомо му як
катаргейт це величезний удар по простий
у парламенту хіба ні абсолютно Так але
там де є влада і там де є політика на
жаль завжди існує великий ризик корупції
і питання в тому як ви з цим впораєтесь
я все своє життя була борцем за
верховенство права І виступала проти
корупції і звичайно Зараз такі люди як
Віктор Орбан прем'єр-міністр Угорщини
говорять Те саме Гаразд Велике спасибі
Вам за те що були з нами в конфлікт зон
завжди рада